[Music]
baber and mid-suffolk district councils
both declared a climate and biodiversity
emergency in 2019
since then we've worked with our suffolk
climate change partnership colleagues to
approve our first carbon reduction
management plan and biodiversity action
plan
these plans set out how we aim to
achieve our ambition to become carbon
neutral by 2030
and how we'll improve and strengthen our
district's plant life and wildlife
our work so far has included becoming
the first rural uk councils to move our
fleet to hydro-treated vegetable oil
a change which will reduce our total co2
emissions by a quarter and reduce our
fleet emissions by up to 90 percent
securing 3.6 million pounds in
government funding to make our homes
more energy efficient and add energy
saving measures and trial solar carport
technology at our leisure centers
supporting our communities with grants
and advice for new green projects such
as electric vehicle charging points
giving out equipment and supporting
hundreds of litter-picking groups to
help keep the districts clean and tidy
working with our suffolk waste
partnership colleagues to help increase
and improve the quality of recycling
across suffolk
but we know there's still more to do and
ways we can support our residents to
reduce their carbon emissions too
find out more and keep up to date with
our progress at
www.greensuffolk.org forward slash news